attracting a diverse workforce is a
priority for air chiefs like society at
large
adverts such as this one is a form of
positive action to draw different faces
into what's traditionally been a largely
white male profession
but defense sources allege the diversity
push may have prompted some positive
discrimination that could impact uk
defenses if some white men are being
unfairly disadvantaged
that would be illegal and a minister
insisted it wouldn't be tolerated no
minister in the mod and no chief of any
service
gets to break the law and so if there is
evidence of positive discrimination
the people responsible for that will be
held vigorously to account the raf has
been in the spotlight this week after
sky news revealed its head of
recruitment had resigned over what
defense sources said were impossible
diversity targets
the sources said she'd quit in protest
following an effective pause on making
job offers to white men in favor of
ethnic minorities and women yet the
minister said the pause was for all new
entrants to allow air chiefs to explore
whether they could use positive action
to boost diversity levels what is
definitely not true is that recruitment
of white men has in any way being paused
it's definitely not true that women and
ethnic minorities are being loaded onto
courses now whilst white men are not but
a former fast jet pilot released this
internal email on his youtube channel
unless
fame and female
tim davies claimed it showed in 2020 the
raf appeared to be willing to hold back
white men from taking an aptitude test
as part of selection though the raf said
the instruction was quickly corrected
this is positive discrimination against
against someone because of an immutable
characteristic which we know in this
case happens to be their skin color and
and their sex it's white men it's
indefensible what's happening right now
within the service in 2015 the
government set a target for all the
armed forces to hit 10 ethnic minority
recruits and 15 female recruits by 2020
the raf alone stretched the target for
women recruits to 20 within that time
frame
in march 2021 the service proudly
announced it had met the targets
but the armed forces own diversity
statistics don't show how these figures
were achieved they described the female
inflow as 18.3 percent and don't provide
a breakdown for ethnic minorities the
raf said the discrepancy is because its
internal data excluded women choosing to
rejoin
leaked documents give a further insight
into how the diversity targets were hit
in the year 2020 to 2021 with sources
alleging women and ethnic minorities
were brought forwards onto training
courses early to boost the statistics
one file revealed the recruitment force
continues to prioritize female
candidates for customer relationship
management
another document sets out how the
bringing forwards of some women into
training courses early had impacted the
following 12 months targets it read the
pipeline remains depleted of women
candidates following the advanced
loading of these candidates in the
fourth quarter of the previous year
an raf spokesperson said all its
recruitment action was legal and said
operational effectiveness is of
paramount importance and no one is
lowering the standards to join the royal
air force the raf recruits for many
professions and like the rest of the
armed forces is determined to be a force
that reflects the society it serves to
protect
the royal air force has a well-earned
reputation for operational excellence
that's founded on the quality of our
people we will always seek to recruit
the best talent available to us
no one's disputing the raf's proud past
but there are internal voices who are
worrying about the forces future
debra haynes sky news